a world war 2 torpedo boat that sank
three enemy ships and took part in two
invasions has returned to its homeport
volunteers at the world war ii Museum in
New Orleans spent more than a decade
restoring PT boat 305 to the way it
looked in 1944 patrol torpedo boats were
among the fastest and most heavily armed
vessels for their size then Navy
lieutenant John F Kennedy commanded a PT
boat in the South Pacific
Omar Villafranca is in New Orleans to
show us the remarkable restoration Omar
good morning good morning
this is PT 305 also known as the USS
sudden jerk and this is exactly what the
boat looked like during World War two
and if you were a German boat and you
saw this vessel that was probably a
torpedo already headed your way after
more than 70 years the vessel is finally
back home and one of the original crew
members took it on another mission after
more than 70 years Jim narration is back
on his boat the last time the former
Navy petty officer stepped on PT 305 he
was about 19 years old and the American
Navy vessel was stationed off the coasts
of France in Italy during world war ii
gave us about to face in a beautiful job
on thursday the 92 year old veteran took
the newly restored vessel on its
inaugural ride on Louisiana's Lake
Pontchartrain sounds the same as it did
then the vibration under your feet the
patrol torpedo or PT boat is the latest
addition to the national World War two
museum in New Orleans there are plenty
of planes ships and other artifacts for
people to see at the Museum but soon
visitors will be able to ride on the
world's only operational PT each vessel
carries four torpedoes before it made it
back to New Orleans the boat was barely
salvageable
Joshua Schick is one of the museum's
curators well I know what a PT's
supposed to look like so she look pretty
sad to me you know she's just a beat-up
old work boat
after her service in world war ii the
vessel kept working as a tour boat in
new york city and an oyster boat in the
Chesapeake Bay
eventually what was left of PT 305 was
found in Texas it was brought to the
museum to start a vigorous 10-year
restoration project it took more than
200 volunteers more than 120 thousand
hours to restore the boat to what it
looked like in World War two
the people who worked on the boat they
say it was all worth it he was
speechless when he came out and I kinda
had to turn away for just a second
collect myself so it's amazing you know
we do all this work we put all his blood
sweat tears into it and to have him
approve is really all I wanted and now
let's teach people about it we had a lot
of fun a one-time torpedo operator Narus
instill has war stories to tell he knew
the one-ton weapon was fueled by
compressed air and 180 proof grain
alcohol sometimes he admits the crew
would sip the fuel just to make sure
they were battle ready the torpedo
wasn't going to use it all anyway so we
kind of tapped off a little bit of it a
little a little bit of torpedo fuel for
yourself
we call a torpedo juice Harrison plans
to ride PT 305 again with his grandkids
so his family can see what it was like
on what he calls his boat you called it
your boat yeah after 70 plus years do
you still feel like it's your boat
absolutely you get attached to a boat
you know anybody that's ever had a boat
of any size gets too attached to it and
you you take care of it you you love it
you know and whether you own it or
whether you're just a seaman on board
it's still your boat and that's the way
I feel about this one I may not own it
but it's still my boat PT 305 ran more
than 70 patrol missions and dropped
countless torpedoes like this one but
she is not ready for retirement next
week she'll start taking history buffs
out for a ride on Lake Pontchartrain
tickets are three hundred and fifty
dollars and that may sound a little bit
pricey but all the tickets for the month
of April are already sold out
Anthony Omar thank you now all praise to
those people who created the world to
museum that's what a life that boat has
had huh and so great that Jim Garrison
could rise it ride it one more time